um so I think this might be a little bit
controversial and and uh exciting that
as we spoke about the last time we had
you on the podcast which was over Zoom
you were talking about how you don't
have access to your official Bam Margera
Instagram account that you've got to
send stuff to another person and they've
got to like approve it and then they'll
post it but perhaps because if you're
frustrated by that Dynamic you went
ahead and opened up a new Instagram
account and it well it was it was
because I if I can't have access to my
Instagram then I can't follow my friends
and see new skate tricks or see what
anybody's up to so I had to start a new
one and just hit follow follow on
everybody who I used to be following and
then slowly I just started posting
photos and then people just started like
catching wind that I have like another
one as well I think that that this will
get you a lot of followers on Instagram
and uh you know in the past with your
Instagram it's been like oh oh boy like
Bam's on one you know and you'd be like
posting some similar and there's been a
little bit of that with the new
Instagram account but not a lot and like
my view on it is that
you know I I think there's there's
something really meaningful about
knowing that it's coming directly from
you yeah well I just have an issue with
Instagram because
everybody who posts it's always like me
and my friend at the beach having a
blast me having dinner with my pal
having a blast everybody's having a
blast how come nobody posed like this
[ __ ] cut me off and gave me a
fender bender I want to kick his [ __ ]
ass you know like it's all just
everybody's just so happy all the time
and there's nothing bad at all
[Laughter]
[Music]
approach
um
and I I unapologetically take that
approach because I just think it's like
a tool for me to entertain people yeah
you know like that's that's my deal I
drive all my different business you know
initiatives by entertaining people and
using that entertainment to draw
attention to so it's that kind of just
worked for me yeah but yeah do we want
to announce what this Instagram account
is
it's just called Captain cream stain
except the best part of it is that it's
misspelled it says did you not know that
what does it say it says
Captain creams no it doesn't yeah I
swear
it's not Captain cream stuff it's not
captain crazy caption cream
Captain would be
t-a-i-n but it's a t-i-a-n
cream yeah
everything's taken everything yeah wow
there it is so that is so classic dude
I'm I'm
really I do not man I'm really enjoying
talking to you like you uh are clearly
uh in a good place man it's warming my
heart do you like shopping on Amazon I
do and good news is Stevo's butt wipes
for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude